ich beginne mit einem bekenntnis ich
habe mich geirrt ich habe hier nämlich
gesagt und zwar auf der basis von
informationen nicht von spekulation er
wird's nicht und nun wird karl
lauterbach doch gesundheitsminister
wie ist das gekommen also warum holt
sich olaf scholz diesen apokalyptiker
ins ins kabinett warum mutet er sich das
zu und uns auch ich glaube da ist zu
erkennen dass eine dass die mechanik der
macht eine eine lücke geöffnet hat die
ihm diese chance eröffnet hat denn
eigentlich war vorgesehen
dass lars klingbeil
verteidigungsminister wird da wäre auch
gut geeignet kommt aus soldatenfamilien
mitglied des verteidigungsausschusses
versteht was von dem thema wird er aber
nicht wenn er das geworden wäre hätte er
den letzten männer platz in dem im
kabinett besetzt und dann wäre eine frau
gesundheitsministerin beworben da
klingbeil allerdings für olaf scholz
wichtiger als spd-vorsitzender ist
nämlich um die partei im zaum zu halten
hat er sich gesagt ich mache den wind
ich setze den klingbeil aus parteiamt
und den lauterbach beherrsche ich schon
selber wenn man einmal allerdings ein
sakko falsch geknüpft hat dann knöpft
man den knopf zu knopf immer weiter
falsch also insofern ist dann auch noch
hinterher gekommen dass boris pistorius
der innenminister von niedersachsen
deren hervorragender kandidat für das
bundesinnenministerium gewesen wäre
nicht zum zuge kommt weil eben der
letzte männer platz schon von karl
lauterbach besetzt ist kann man jetzt
lange über diese quoten frage regeln die
spd hat es so entschieden und lauterbach
ist gesundheitsminister die reise nach
jerusalem hat karl lauterbach gewonnen
er sitzt auf dem stuhl und alle anderen
laufen noch ein kreis so was bedeutet
das jetzt erleben wir diese apokalypse
die er so in den letzten zwei jahren
immer wieder vor sich hergetragen hat
erleben wird das täglich im kabinett
dann möchte ich etwas hoffnung geben
denn ein wenig hoffnung geben denn ich
glaube das könnte auch anders kommen wir
haben jetzt schon erlebt dass er
sehr moderat gegen die gegen den
lockdown gesprochen hat er hat außerdem
in aussicht gestellt dass es zu
weihnachten reisefreiheit gibt das ist
ein neuer ton bei ihm eigentlich hätte
er vom reisen um weihnachten früher noch
gewarnt und zwar ganz entschieden wenn
nicht sogar das verbot von längeren
reisen verlangt das tut er nicht ich
halte es für möglich dass er hat sein
geschäftsmodell wechselt und zwar von
apokalypse zu vertrauen also jetzt als
minister ins ziel sieht die welt ganz
anders aus da braucht er auch eine
andere verwurzelung im volk und
vielleicht verändert sich der karl
lauterbach etwas und zwar angeleitet von
olaf scholz der ihm hat man heute schon
gesehen als ein vorgestellt hat jan
bestimmte dinge ganz sicher nicht
durchgehen lässt also leute entspannt
euch etwas muss nicht so schlimm kommen
wie es aussieht also und die erstmal
müssen wir die alle hier respekt zollen
vor so einem großartigen tv publikum
einen fehler einzugestehen einen tip-in
einzukassieren den wir gemacht das ist
ja schon mal super ich war glaube ich
der sendung hier du sprach sogar davon
die spd sei ja nicht die bbw ja verrückt
wenn sie ihn
als minister machen würden das würde ich
auch
da wird der sohn könne die fdp nicht mit
dir eine regierung will na ja aber ganz
im ernst ich finde man dabei einer eine
sache da nicht vergessen taktische
partei gründe hin und her fakt ist
mindestens die hälfte aller deutschen
die marke karl lauterbach die wollte
karl lauterbach es ist also quasi eine
entscheidung des volkes und ich finde
dass ehrlicherweise auch mal ganz schön
dass möglicherweise die spd tatsächlich
auch mal darauf gehört hat wen denn die
leute hier draußen wollen man muss sich
nicht mögen ist die 50 die mögen aber 50
prozent der wählerinnen und wähler
hatten ihr interesse daran dass jahr
lauterbach diesen job macht ich
persönlich hab eine ganz wilde theorien
ich glaube und das wäre so wunderbar
dass karl lauterbach in drei oder vier
monaten arbeitslos ist denn irgendwie
würde das passen der ist ja nicht
gesundheitsminister sondern der ist ein
cooler minister jetzt geworden und
irgendwie würde das zu ihnen passen kaum
ist ein minister hat er gar nichts mehr
zu tun weil wir corona endlich
überwunden haben das wäre eine schöne
nachricht für uns alles wäre nicht so
schön für karl lauterbach und übrigens
eine sache auch noch der allererste der
ist wusste war glaube ich sein friseur
denn spektakuläres gesehen hat am
sonntag der neue hersteller von karl
lauterbach dabei
er hat sich dem minister haarschnitt
zugelegt hatte seinen friseur der am
sonntagmorgen wahrscheinlich an tanz
musste er wusste also kann man als indiz
dafür nehmen dass er sehr spät erfahren
hat dass vorher noch ein paar andere
bälle in der luft waren bei olaf scholz
und dass er das ganz zum schluss
aufgefangen hat uns gedacht mist ich
nehme doch
und nun hat er ihn und da kann ich nur
sagen ich will dem urlaub scholz nicht
alles gute wünschen ich will uns alles
gute wünschen dass der mann jetzt zu
einer abgewogenen ruhigen nicht
aufputschenden nicht hysterie sieren
amtsführung kommt und so was wie
neuanfang macht bisher unterscheidet er
sich von jens spahn so gut wie gar nicht
und ich hätte aber schon ganz gerne ein
paar unterschied zu jens sparen es
sollte schon was neues losgehen oder
auch mit euch in der fdp
ist immer gut
ich muss ihnen sagen ja ich würde ihn zu
rufen wunderbar wenn die krone endlich
gefunden hatten und übrigens
wahrscheinlich alle zuschauer und
zuschauerinnen auch weil gerade das ist
ja durchaus für alle beteiligten
stressig bei der personalauswahl der spd
war die fdp natürlich nicht eingebunden
das macht die spd schon unter sich aus
und ich bisschen aufmachen musste als
sie gesagt haben männer platz da scheint
es dass die spd mittlerweile schon
männer plätze musste also aus meiner
sicht aus meiner uhr liberalen haltung
heraus erzählt natürlich erstmal die
kompetenz und dann natürlich auch das
commitment dass man vielfältig sein
möchte in allen bereichen und belangen
deshalb würde ich jetzt nie männer platz
nennen oder nie den frauen platz sondern
ich würde am ende sagen auf
unterschiedlichen position haben wir
unterschiedlich kompetente menschen die
das voran erstellen zum jahr
werde mich total ich fühle mich total zu
aber es ist leider so die verhandlung
haben sich so ein bisschen gedreht
früher hat man mir frauenplätze geredet
jetzt redet man über männer plätze sowie
man über weiße alte männer wie mich
redet ja die bekommen verschiedene
sachen nicht mehr und jetzt ist in der
spd auch so weit dass mindestens die
gleiche zahl an frauen ministerinnen
wird und in diesem fall
haben sie sogar die nase vorne wenn man
urlaub scholz weglässt sind die frauen
im kabinett vorne da ist ja auch gar
nichts dagegen zu sagen aber nach
kompetenz geht das nicht unbedingt finde
ich denn sonst wäre boris pistorius
innenminister geworden das würde nicht
aber ganz kurz also herr lauterbach für
das ministerium gesundheit deutlich mehr
kompetenz grundsätzlich mitbringt als
hafen alle
anderen minister erinnern die haben in
ihrer karriere fünf ministerposten
gemacht von innenminister über italien
über also es war nicht immer bei uns in
der regierung so dass die absolute
kernkompetenz dafür gesorgt hat dass man
mindestens zwei selbst duden kanada bach
jetzt wie findest du das als bürger gut
ja also ich bin auch eigentlich ist so
der meinung dass wir halt einfach eine
kompetente person brauchen die dann die
richtigen entscheidungen trifft und
es wird sich herausstellen auch wie sich
die ganze situation im land entwickelt
das ist ja auch so eine frage wo wir
alle nicht wissen was passiert was wird
kommen keine untergang hat eben als die
stimme des volkes bezeichnet die
wahrheit ist dass das
wäre das wunderbar wir hätten eine
basisdemokratie der herrlich zart ich
kann das bloß nicht feststellen in
diesem fall war es sicher spielte das
ein großer jahre bei der polizei und
auch die festlegung der medien für ihn
die ich ein bisschen überraschend fand
aber das war eindeutig so die medien
ich habe heute ein paar songs
geschrieben haben gesagt herzlichen dank
an sich das gesundheitsminister ist was
ich sagen will ich war immer sehr stark
gegen karl lauterbach er hat mir einmal
großen respekt abverlangt da hab ich ihn
hier in der sendung als hampelmann
bezeichnet das weiß nicht nur in bester
monroe meiner karriere kam er am
dienstag in die sendung hier hin ich
habe mich bei ihm entschuldigt dazu
steht bis heute das war einfach daneben
von mir das macht man nicht dass es das
respektiere ich man braucht ein aspekt
darauf kommen wir spieler noch er hat
sich hingesetzt er hatte lust am
debattieren er war offen er hat die
entschuldigung angenommen und das ist
das wo ich sage wo ich glaube ich gut
finde dass es karl lauterbach geworden
weil er hat lust auch mit menschen zu
reden die nicht seiner meinung sehr lust
zu überzeugen ein lustiger diskussion zu
gehen und ich hoffe wenn er sich diese
für mich ist es schon sehr demokratisch
so zu handeln dass es gut für unsere
demokratie und da muss ich sagen ich bin
da eigentlich dankbar dass erst geworden
ist und nicht wieder irgendwer den
menschen und medien aus ich sag mal dazu
ich habe ihn ja als apokalyptischer
bezeichnet so habe ich noch wahrgenommen
weil er immer das schlimmste befürchtet
hat und die leute gewandt und gewarnt
und gewann ton gebrannt hat er hat auch
nicht immer richtig gelegen mit dem
wasser medizinisch angemerkt hat dann
macht man jetzt mal den schwamm drüber
aber ich glaube eingestanden hat er hat
im nachgang hatten studie vorgeführt
worden ist er hat ein paar politiker er
hat ein paar hunderttausend talkshows
gesehen und dann musste das zugeben aber
er ist ein sehr intelligenter sehr
analytischer mensch das muss ich auch
sagen und mein trost ist auch ein
bisschen die gesundheitspolitik dieser
neuen koalition wird sicher nicht von
ihm alleine festgelegt sondern wird in
der koalition beschlossen und ganz
wesentlich auch im kanzleramt und unter
einschluss der fdp und da kann man nur
hoffen dass bürgerrechte da jetzt auch
mit eine rolle spielen
bürgerrechte ist immer gutes stichwort
nachdem wir ja auch in dem falle des
justizministerium stellen und mit marco
buschmann sicherlich ein prämierten
vorkämpfer auch für bürgerrechte in der
zukunft haben denke ich das sicherlich
das sei ausgewogen diskutiert werden
muss und sicherlich ist auch harte sache
geht aber das wird zahl wird sich ihm
zeigen gerade im nächsten wochen